[Music]
so like most live shows we have a
warm-up comedian who comes out before we
tape and gets the crowd all excited but
here at the Pete home show we like to
have someone come out and calm down the
audience to help them segue back to
their regular lives so ladies and
gentlemen I give you for the first time
ever audience cool down comedian TIG
[Music]
Naro
please
guys I know we've had some laughs
tonight but we can't be acting like this
as we walk out into the world and we
can't have this sort of joy in our
regular
lives sh
please
please come
here come here come
here this is so good this is exactly how
you want to leave a comedy
show you guys are doing
great I'm
sorry neglecting you
guys sh please please we're almost
there
ma'am when you leave here don't make a
sound and promise me that you'll go to
bed when you get
home if you had other plans just go home
and go to
bed thank you so
much tigar everybody sorry they're all
[Applause]
[Music]
JB